this one's funny this is from Omar is a
garbage to pay off tonight's tickets in
multiple
payments trying to spread that [__]
around come talk to me next month will
you waiting on a few things to shake out
gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you standup comedy plus we
play a little AIG with the crowd shows
are selling out and you can get your
tickets at rug garbage.com see you
[Music]
there welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
new favorite podcast this is Ru garbage
sure it's that little show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and we find
it at the group to be classy yeah to
just a big old whole piece of trash
trash trash trash I'm your host a Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at toies in the new
edition she's upstairs getting you just
swallowed a burp I did not how dare you
I apologize and to's upstairs filling
out our Wheels okay yeah for wait she's
filling out our Wheels yeah okay
shockingly left it all to herself smart
broad uhhuh she knows we're going to be
traveling a lot uhhuh she's looking for
something to happen yeah broad's cutting
her brake L [__] Wing gum off for
something my co-host is coming at you
from across the table he is the CEO of
Ru garbage it's all his fault give it up
for KJ Kevin James put that [__] hate
on me goddamn in case the feds are
listening jez what's up I'm a Psy you're
a fsy what's up everybody thanks for
tuning in I'm a fany paty as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are TR
of cooking cing and obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
SL are you garbage you go over there you
sign up you get a bajillion hours of of
content over there and also it's last
couple of days uh if you sign up for
patreon in a October of 2023 you'll be
entered into contest to be interviewed
by big man and myself on an app of are
you garbage look at that yes still
tweaking all the Deets but get in there
and it's a good
time having my lawyer go over all the
paperwork send you a bus
ticket
he get to talk to two guys who look like
us Kelvin and
schmy man that that would be dude hold
on four we should hire two actors that
look like us so when the person person
sits down you guys look way different on
K just they look like us just a little
off he camera ads them pound I to tell
ah yeah good stuff I told you that I'm
sure you going to introduce Toby Jesus H
Christ oh man the big man's on the
frit gang how about a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones the twos the threes and the
fours he's easily forgettable cross is
the dies Tony McDougall he's so good you
don't even know he's there give it up
for T-Bone MC scruin Toby McMullen
everybody they call me the fly on the
wall put a bell on you or something I
forgot about it what up dog hey pal what
up t-one what's cooking nothing having a
nice time kib's got a little bit of
lunch lady voice going oh man this is
called heaters and beers this is brought
to you by Philip
Morris two went heavy on a heaters doing
a little gurgling over there oh man
telling you the heaters in the fall and
the winter it's overrated man I want to
get off them I want to get out of them
okay and I no one's stopping you I know
I know I know it's on me I get it
thought about that nicotine gum
back why did
youer nicotine gu hey [__] Jack relax
will you chewing that nicotine G um and
the the the I got to figure out
something for the winner with the color
now we're [__] we're going on the cruise
I'm showing up [__] like I just
walked off [__] out of the Chop House
in Idaho or something like that in the
middle of winter okay I don't know
what's that all about I work in a
slaughter house and I know I assume
those guys don't get get a lot of sun
you know sure I wanted I wanted to be a
little a little you know little go go
get go to a tanning B I know but it's
not that great that doesn't come out
right I'm a sun guy you give me the Sun
a couple of days later plus this really
breaks the facade man the [__] yellow
under my eyes look like I'm washing my
face with mustard got a bad case of
jundas it's the most Philadelphia
disease you can have y [__]
yikes [__] yellow skin yellow teeth
[__] all banged up have a lemon will
you kid to love a lemon that's good for
jaundice isn't it lemon or is that
scurvy that scurvy okay that's what the
British Sailors used to get when they
were crossing the Atlantic anyway sure I
don't yeah I wish I I wish I was a
little bit little I had a little bit
better color and I got nothing yet to
wear well yeah here's the thing we're
going uh Berke chrys shout out
Big Bert y fully loaded Cruise baby
fully loaded Cruise uh the boys are set
in sale uh this weekend we're going to
be know [__] anchors up bombs away a
Hoy M the whole nine yards and this is
where this is our first cruise and
obviously Cruises have been well
documented on this podcast over the past
few years check out for Better or For
Worse check out the Christmas episode
that's how you're going to get here
that's how you're going to get here to
be on Ru Gage you're going to take
kippy's Cruise no it's actually the
episode after the Christmas episode I
think is the is the real is the real
feel I got Kippy a cruise for Christmas
last year why you bringing up old
[__] he did not appreciate it well
Bert's paying me to go on the cruise um
yeah so I think we
will our first cruise for each of us I
thinku I think we will come into our
full form on a cruise yeah I mean it's
pretty much unlimited food really yeah
unlimited food unlimited
booze just like [__] heaters go Lord
there's a casino on board whoa I didn't
know that yeah so I think it's going to
we're going to be you're going to be
crer does it right doesn't he we're
shout out to the machine yeah dude I'm
going to be in I'm going to be in the
pool going to hop out of the pool have a
heater have a my tie go play the tables
go grab a lobster bis come back out jump
in a pool do a show Lobster bis on a
cruise in felt seafoody I don't know
it's the summer down there still October
Baby I don't know what you want for
me I eat by Seasons okay not temperature
turt NE in a bathing suit man is the
casino open all night I think it's 24/7
on cruises I don't know can you get a
look on that I would presume it's
international waters baby we're going to
be I'm I'm I'm I want to get some
[__] I did order some I got to see if
how stay away from the railing how it
fell buddy I'm staying in the center of
the hole you know what I
mean a lot of people wouldn't mind
getting me out of the way [__] push
me over um end up like a [__] 60
Minutes episode um I think um I'm
excited I want to I got some fresh gear
coming I hope it fits I got a few things
I want to go full [__] Cabana having
fun doing it or I'm [__] in it baby
you're on a cruise you got to [__]
live Liv America me too my only problem
is is that the the
DXL uh they're not they're going to have
all FAL
[__] you can still get bathing suits and
stuff not no what are you talking about
they they switch it over over you think
they got room for all that [__] in the
back yeah a lot of fabric yeah dude they
got to get rid of that stuff they start
rolling that stuff out around late
August mhm it's all sweatshirts and [__]
like
that I want to look fresh though maybe
I'll hit one down there in Miami before
we get before before we hop on a boot
there you go yeah still have tags on me
and [__] take it back afterwards sir
where you going with that where you
going with them trunks you're running
out the front ton what do you got on the
ship all right so you're setting sail
because I will not be attending cuz I'm
not a cruise guy uh you that's right we
got new guy Luke coming new guy Luke's
on the cruise well I needed to send you
guys out there with the with the Boozer
you know what I mean true no I get it as
and Toby Cabin Boy Toby is a uh soberman
right well well you know a non-drinking
man there you go and you know it
wouldn't be that's a tough thing for a
sober boy to be on you know that's a lot
of partying in a confined space that's a
knife fight there could be people
walking around with blenders under their
arms c as me your boss hey what's up bro
does Luke have his own room or is he is
he Luke's got his own room okay he's
going to sleep in one of the
lifeboats be ready well stow away yeah
all right you'll be setting sail on the
beautiful Norwegian Pearl ooh Norwegian
Pearl
93,500 ft of good times on thought how
shrimp on there to you're goddamn right
uh 2,300 guest capacity uh
uh it was refurbished in 2021 so it was
going to be tip top shape okay I don't
like the word refurbished if I'm being
honest with you on the vessel tuna boat
2300 Souls on that b boy a certified
pre-owned cruise ship got it at Carfax
or CarMax no carvana what is it got it
at Lenny's Yacht
Sales all right you got a bunch of
dining options okay for your 24hour eery
there we go Toby with the [__] cold
hard facts that we need I'm going to
accidentally leave my o [__] no no no
this is going to be right up your alley
I can already tell oenin bar and grill
ah
shenin I I might cry that's that's
[__] me stumbling in there at 3:30
getting some [__] you know some
bangers and mash or some fish and chips
or something the kitchen's open too
24-hour Eatery and drinkery you got a
menu they got no they got no uh I this
was a 12 deck Buffet no it's a buffet on
Deck
12 damn I kind of wish it was a 12 deck
Buffet never get to the end of that
thing I'm eating through the
hall and sealing up doors yeah this
place looks all right a Norwegian that's
nice yeah then you got the uh you got SC
you got the Garden Cafe skip that Lotus
Garden anything but Garden I'm going to
imagine you'll want I got to do a salad
a day I'll take that bet
yeah I gotta keep it tight I got the
[__] oics I can really see it doing
the line I'm not doing any salads now I
think about it it's like four days I'm
doing I'm going I'm B I'm doing burgers
for breakfast 24-hour room service nice
hello nice the Summer Palace looks nice
what's uh what are the casino rules on
that on that on that vessel there t uh
give me give me anybody little play ball
uh you got any dealers that are jammed
up with the sharks
put this screws to them I'll tell you
even if they're tipping their cards
won't help you that much speaking from
experience all right you got a world
class Spa that's all right Ah that's
nice they're normally not open 24 hours
a day but they are open late nights cool
oh they got a Starbucks star beeses I
get my egg bites oh yeah casinos and
shops 250 calories for those uh kale
kale mushroom ones you do two of them a
nice breakfast sure and a coffee mhm
okay I'm looking for the casino she says
they're not and when you port they close
them plus you could take laps around the
around the uh the the the boat to get
your exercise get your steps in I'm in a
perfect world perfect world mhm hit the
gym since it's there sure get a sweat
jump in the pool typically when we stay
at a hotel that has that we'll you know
I'll try to get some sort of action
definitely jump in the pool oh yeah I'm
I'm in a pool all daying got a pool
right we're doing an episode from the
pool are we really no what that' be cool
uh I don't know if it'll be offered
during your Voyage but they do do Deal
or No Deal on the trip which is fun what
like the game show yeah Ah that's
probably non that's probably like their
entertainment when it's not a bur Cruise
you know what sure uh but we got a lot
of f a lot of fun stuff planned it's
going to be cool yeah can't wait they
got basketball volleyball and Tennis
Courts yeah card room there you go what
like tarot cards you go walk in pick a
card any card nope oh no it's like
bridge and stuff oh get out of here
never played Bridge maang did a little
I've I've done a little Jin Ry before
but never Bridge Denise started playing
maang recently yeah really uhhuh I
thought that was just for Jewish ladies
that's what she said her I guess her
friends uh you know the her and the the
her Jewish games they play good good to
see it yeah so she's playing much she's
like I'm like what are you doing she
goes I was just playing maang I said who
are you niece she's cleaning them all
out 40 buay in boys I'm telling you
right now it's deck six has it all going
on what do you got they got your buffet
and the Pearl Casino baby that's what
I'm talking about that's where you'll
find me if you're on there come check me
out I'm going be shaking them up shake
them up really screaming at a blackjack
dealer no I SC no no scream at the cards
not the dealer yes if the Dealer's
giving me the cards that's his problem
little collateral damage
it'll be fun first cruise me and you
look at that look at how things work out
know I buy a cruise you keep saying that
you don't like it sure now we're going
on a cruise together sure so maybe this
might be the holy [__] I love it and
then you're going to be you're going
you're going to be going we rehashing
this whole thing I've always wanted I
like the idea of going on a cruise
yes that's a [__] problem
then you gave me one with a deadline
that had to use in 60
days hurricane season if I I got your
bags packed if I remember correctly get
you down there all right let's quit
screwing around Gang This is a goddamn
Family episode uhhuh just the boys the
bozos and the homies just the way we
like it if you don't know when you sign
up for the old patreon you get a q
answered who [__] got cruises on the
brain when you sign up for the old
patreon as you know when you okay no
yeah let's get it and take it from the
top when you sign up on the patreon as
no as you know when you sign up on the
patreon you sign up for a cruise ship as
you know when you sign up on the patreon
you get your question answered on the
air dude [__] giy
what damn dig it's all perfect it
ain't dude what just happened to you
that hasn't happened in 400 episodes
that was crazy when you sign up for the
patreon you could have your question
answered on the air by Tony
McMuffins Tony McMuffins
Tony McMuffins is all right High fixure
Tony McMuffins is like a lounge singer
hey Tony McMuffins how are you doing hey
he's got a life for the kid give it up
for the hash browns
everybody that's his backup that's his
hash
browns and like the powder blue
suit this next one's coming with a side
of funk I hate
myself hey can we 86 can we 86 Toby
we're leaving you at the next Port I
found out do you know the origin of 86
yeah
restaurants yeah I mean it's a term used
in restaurants you know the origin they
only had 86 Entre what it was at the 86
LNG it was on the 86th day when they ran
out of potatoes no are we close shipment
in 86th no not at all uhuh what does it
have to what does it pertain to give us
a little bit of a clue prohibition
prohibition 86th that was the 6
amendment in the Constitution
what D that's a big Constitution you got
there son if that was the 86th Amendment
how many amendments are there 18 n 24 24
23 that was close I don't know it was
three how many amendments I might be
thinking
Stars it's I think it's it's in the 20s
27 27 27 Amendments all right it has to
do with prohibition it was 86 we 86ed it
86 86 that was the signal if the cops
were coming uh kind of close Okay that
was the that it was that was the that
was what they said over the radio hey we
got an 86 in progress they're
drinking
uh no it was you don't even know I do
I'm trying to give you the exact thing
cuz I knew you're going to [__] break
my balls about it it's going to happen
either way um
oh that's my favorite H Foley move throw
a fact his way and he goes I don't know
about that sure yeah and then I'm like
I'm like just have to go then I have to
look it up so I was trying to have so I
can't find it which is making me think
it's not
right just say where does 86 come from
uh I did but it just goes back to uh oh
there it is uh prohibition er a bar
called Chum's yeah CH isn't that New
York yes located at 86 Bedford Street I
believe uh still be there if I'm not
misten I think the door is so the there
was two entrances there was the front
entrance to the thing and it was uh
known all the cops were in on it okay
right that they knew it was happening
love that but they would get a call down
like hey we got to crack down uhhuh uh
we coming in they would call like
whatever stop by and say 86 it and the
back the back exit dumped you out at
like 86 Bedford Street so 86 of them was
get everybody out the back like [__]
clear it out look at that it's stuck and
that that I just saw it on Instagram
whatever that door that 86 door is still
there like they keep it yeah man 86 it
86 the the [__] boys are coming down
cuz it was a different it wasn't the
local cops it was like the [__]
[__] Elliot Ness yeah it was the
looker control board [__] feds they come
in they said hey the [__] the
alphabet boys are coming an 86 The Joint
[__] Hoover was coming down Cherry
tops pulling up yikes yeah what what was
there beef with that let the boys drink
I don't know they rolled in thick tommy
guns and [__] might be political
statement let the guys drink they work a
hard day they can't come home and have a
[__] cold
one [__] is the 1920s these [__]
guys are dying can't have a little Mash
whatever they were drinking back then
some [__] Hooch some rock and Ry let
the boys [__] get after it that's all
I'm saying I give it to you K let's talk
about better help oh man shout out to
better help K me ask you ever feel like
you know what's good for you but you
can't make yourself actually do it nope
you want good things to happen you want
to good night's sleep but can't quite
chase away the racing thoughts nope you
want to leave your soul sucking job but
don't have the confidence to take your
risk yep talking to a therapist over
there better help can help you figure
out what's holding you back so you
finally move forward I was jammed up a
little bit couldn't find find a
therapist that I liked I did a little
better help over there little text
Little Talk little this little that do
it all for the Privacy your home home
own home own home better help is totally
online convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule uh you can do therapy by
video call over the phone or even by
message whatever works best for you and
that's what better health does it makes
it easy peasy for you it gets you in the
pool it figures it out it's a daunting
task to call up some old loser in the
upper west side and go talk to him he
called your dad a dicket it's a whole
thing you don't want to deal with it
sound personal go to Better Health just
fill out a brief questionnaire to get
match and uh with a license therapist
and get started on your journey make
your brain your friend baby with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com garbage
today to get 10% off your first month
that's better help
hp.com garbage do it gang yeah K this is
bespoke post baby shout out to the post
shout out to the box of awesome you like
doing cool guy stuff or you a [__]
loser you're not you're a cool guy so
get over there to the spoke post and get
your box Awesome every month it's
absolutely fantastic their box of
awesome is a monthly subscription
service that send you cool curated gear
from the best small Brands around
the world from camping gear to Autumn
cocktail upgrades and even supplies to
help you with better sex whoa I've been
using that blender wrong boys are
getting into the naughty naughty that's
what I'm talking about uh yeah guys it's
awesome it's one of those things the
holidays are coming up you're going to
be having people over you're going to be
over people's house and this is when you
can really Flex on one of that one of
your [__] cousins or something nice
martini shaker they come already start
running their Yap oh you're still here
and you're like oh how about I [__]
tort Your Whiskey real quick a cocktail
yeah [__] really show him who's boss
but gu you still dating that [__] wife
of yours getting started is easy check
out my new hammock just take the quiz
over box ofawesome.com and get match
with the right box for you each box is
valued at around 70 bucks but you pay
just a fraction of that price baby 90%
of everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small upcoming brand
so you're building a collection of
amazing gear while supporting small
businesses cuz this is America get 20%
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box ofawesome.com enter the code
garbage at checkout that's box
ofawesome.com code garbage for 20% off
your first box box ofawesome.com codee
garbage do it yeah the spoke post also
wants you to know that not all your
cousins wives are [__] some of them
are bat and betting but all that's
either here nor there like the big man
said it's a goddamn Family episode um
all right let's see this one's from
calzone edti home run of a name by the
way calone edti is all right e d d y
Double D call him uh were you an eded
and Edy guy oh yeah really I missed it
but I always wanted to be cuz I love the
name Double D were you a Powerpuff girl
he want to be what the [__] you say to
me
bro were you a Powerpuffs girl fan not
really there was another cartoon around
that they were they were all drawn like
that around that time lab and such
Dexter labor Dexter's Lab was all right
sure DD running around causing some
Havoc yeah he had a dog or something
with him right that was smart didn't he
didn't the dog know what was going on no
you're thinking of Mr Peabody no I know
Mr Peabody are you kidding me I don't
know who that is yeah Mr Peabody shut up
you yeah that's Mr Peabody oh yeah maybe
I don't know it you know what gives me
you know what de presses me when I see
it what Wallace and grommet who the [__]
is that you know you have to know the
wrong trousers grommet the wrong if
there was one nerd who grew up with
Wallace and grommet it's [__] Toby
McMuffins over here who's Wallace MC
who's that Wallace and gr was clation
yeah British clamation show dude that
[__] freaked me out man I remember
seeing Gumby when I was a kid like what
the [__] is this I can't eat this guy I
didn't like the clamation that he not
made a gum at all I like that uh Robot
Chicken though oh the best yeah but the
clamation man just seemed creepy no he
was a inventor right and he would invent
all this stuff mhm give me a peek I am
oh man dude talk about creeping you out
I don't like that
[__] oh get the [__] out of here with
that guy seen that dude before he looks
like
powder hey buddy buddy get some color
will you go throw some spoons or
something in the woods yeah no that [__]
was no good when I was a little kid for
a while like the Muppets were like
popular but then there was like bunch of
different like other production
companies that tried to do [__] like
that and and they had like
um uh [__] what was the name of that
they were it wasn't zubal zooo but it
was something weird where they were like
Monsters zubba mufu no no zubal zo had
um uh Ben not Ben Greer Ben uh he he
played um Frankl no he played it was
Will Smith's dad in uh Fresh Prince that
episode that he showed up Ben verine Ben
verine huge star like Broadway star
singer dancer multi-talented guy they
had a show called zubal zooo you got
that yeah yeah oh HR puffing stuff
that's what I'm thinking of oh that guy
cool get the [__] out of here with that
that they were smoking weed and my uncle
my uncle showed me him when I was like
eight I told my mom don't let him back
over here ever again was [__] fre he
thought he was going to be like check
this out I was like buddy I just [__]
myself got to change my drawers order
the pizza what are we doing it's the
last time you Babys me un put on Trading
Places and zipping with you I'll take my
egos
now I said that to my aunt one time look
at my OS in a Sak Quil will you calm the
[__] down get out of you with that HR
puffing stuff nah that [__] was
frightening I said that to my aunt one
time she won't let me I was like seven
or whatever and she was watching me and
I told her hey when my mom gets back
you're out of
here don't get too comfortable DS I
don't like the way you're running this
joint and then I went into the fridge I
vaguely remember this I went into the
fridge got a box of Eggo waffles she was
like watching TV or whatever I walked
hand up to her said I'll take my I'll
take my waffles now she was like this
[__] not those
break imagine a fat six-year-old [__]
an your box 4:00 in the afternoon it was
probably dinner time dude I used to like
an Eggo for a
d oh man I was a picky eater
dude dude I like how you knew where they
were but didn't know how they get
[Laughter]
hot hey lady can you use magic so I can
eat
these I go get the hair dryer and eat
these up I'm not allowed to use
appliances I'll be outside catching a
smoke if you need
me
a break you helpless
brick kick rocks when my mom's back
you're out of here I did like your guys
cartoons a little bit though I just
really couldn't get too too close with
them but but I they were good what we
talking about Doug was all right shout
out to Doug funny p p Mayo Roger clz
graduated kid look like Roger CL was
that were you guys uh The Boondocks was
that your eror or was that more always
that was after me that was probably more
towards him but that was like an adult
cartoon it was for teenagers yeah never
got
it I thought it was great it's funny
yeah oh jeez man oh man we didn't get to
[__] czone Eddy's question we went
off uh calzone Eddy dime bag homeboy
here $10 homie shout out to you is it
garbage to buy a fancy espresso machine
and use Nest quick chocolate powder
instead of actual espresso to make
drinks delicious that's a heightened
you're technically doing something
classy cuz you're classing up Nest quick
you're you're you're you're having a
very
foofy chocolate milk yeah or hot
chocolate when I worked at the Greek
place we had a real expensive espresso
machine and the way they would make
chocolate milk is they had like like
kitchen chocolate like pellets you like
used to like melt the [__] down and they
would do it on their espresso machine in
the in the silver thing that holds the
milk dude we used to [__] man the
combinations were endless uhuh coming up
with everything using the
using the instant coffee with the
chocolate and the milk and the this and
the that oo so I don't know that's
pretty uh it's not CL I mean it is I on
the one end you're buying an expensive
machine if that's all you're using to
for that's trashy if you're having fun
classy kitcheny and the only thing with
that is if you got the espresso machine
what do you doing making the hot
chocolate with water you do that with
the milk he might be steaming milk no he
said he uses it to he uses that instead
of the espresso powder so that's water
100% I I I'm reading it the same way as
but if you make a shot of it and then
add the milk that's what I'm saying you
add it to the milk you're steaming
you're steaming milk instead of the
espresso the coffee grounds you're using
the nest quick powder which is only a
little bit of water there you go I'm
with you you know what would be awesome
you take a little bit of that cocoa
powder mix it in with the espresso
coffee and now you got a nice mocha
espresso now you got a tutor that's what
I call that fcking [__] up wake you up
H like that
that's all right though I I respect that
I'll give it to you um all right this
one's from 2in Stinger shout out to you
um are you garbage if you washed your
body at a coin operated car wash Jesus
Christ I take your skin off you your
human body yeah yeah you couldn't you
they my parents always said if that
thing hit you it would cut you that's
what they say the sprayer that does the
car yeah that's not going to cut I mean
that' be taking the pain off too if it's
going to cut through your skin that's
true huh I would assume another lie by
Patty yeah add that to the list they
keep me in the car I assume that this is
some sort of dir manual labor job where
you're I don't think he's showering
before a date no that's a hose off he's
cleaning off to get in the car like you
know before he goes home which I always
say Landscaping I love the hose off in
the summer loved it last house of the
day go in there get the Palm Olive in
case you had any poison ivy on you
[__] just take your shirt shoes off
leave your jean shorts on and soak down
you were cool for the ride home felt
great yeah felt great I respect that
yeah I assume we would do it sometimes
jumping in the pool right away sure love
that I mean it's not the classiest thing
but it gives you a good good whoosh you
know what I mean after a hard day of
[__]
labor um I respect it this is from H
Wilson H is for hogi shout out to you is
it garbage used pliers to turn off the
bathtub faucet because the knob fell
off I I mean in a pinch I'll give it to
I'll give you a month to get that fixed
we had a wrench on the hot water for
maybe six months one time when I was a
kid just tightened on
there yeah I'm envisioning pliers with
rubber bands to secure to secure like a
set of vice grips that's different
they're classy vice grips are all right
but if you just got regular pliers might
even just be sitting there and you got
to pick it up every time and do it
that's real dangerous espe [__] if
you [__] strip that and can't get it
it won't turn off or something oh
man um I used to hate that when the
thing on the sink would go there was
some things in the Foley household the
sink here the kitchen sink here is all
[__] up I think that's just hot water
no it's a bad mixing valve I believe H
look at you a mixing valve that 3/4 inch
or 8 by5 that's not a thing but it would
Pro a domestic waterline run into a
[__] sink it's probably 3/4 in no not
3/4 inch probably half inch
okay quote me on that pull out the New
York City [__] code book codes uh
half inch domestic water line run into
one feeding one sink half inch got to be
um it's all hot
water yeah it's a bad mixing valve the
valve in it isn't combining the hot and
the cold cuz if you like jiggle it a lot
or twist like you can go any way and get
hot water with that handle that ain't
good yeah that's bad you really got to
find the sweet spot for something cold
and it's really cooking too man
especially in the winter when the
[__] steam's involved that hot water
is burn I got something I want to talk
to you about we were at a hotel recently
not in the same room separate rooms we
we don't shack up um the [__] uh oh I
know where you're going with this the
showers too much the shower knobs at
like a hotel that's trying to be cool
yeah what are you doing yeah it's like
it took me 2 minutes to figure out how
to turn it on get hot water out of the
[__] hole I was looking for what
Kevin's talking about is it'll be a a
showerhead it'll have the the handle
thing and it yeah it'll have the the
hose the brush there'll be a there'll be
the turning thing will be for all of
them will be on the thing the the the
[__] handheld should have a thing on
it where you turn it where you open that
and I'm going to say this all you a
combination of levers and knobs to get
it to where you want to go with no
instructions if you're going to have
something complicated just [__] work
on the water pressure that's all anybody
in a hotel cares we don't need the
[__] handle you don't need all that
[__] you need a [__] hot shower in a
hotel room the next morning after you're
all [__] up that's what you need M
something steaming yeah you don't need
that [__] you worry about all that stuff
you get the fancy mowing in and Coler
whatever it is sure showerheads and the
[__] water pressure sucks it's like
you're getting [__] peed on they do I
did that last night that's what I'm
trying to get off me yeah I think they
do that to save water they don't get
they they give the high heat it's not
you know they don't give it let me tell
you
something any [__]
Empire any [__] civilization once
that water pressure starts going it's
all downhill downhill priorities in yeah
in the turlet which by the way one of
the airbnbs we were at I want to say it
was where was I in the basement was that
San Diego I was in the basement no
Denver Denver that water
pressure God damn oh I stayed in that
shower a long time oh that's all anybody
wants good good water pressure yeah
nobody gives a [__] about your rainfall
and the other thing you know the hose
the hose is old the hose was cool when
it when that was the main thing and it
came off and you could do your but hole
you don't need the side hose Ladies by
the way the side hose now it's it's a
strip it's a line you know what I mean
it's a rectangle yeah what the
[__] I don't
know what are we going to do um oh I
don't think I told you I got to figure
this out at the
house uh I got like a water softener or
something you have soft water I don't
know did you look downstairs yeah they
would have told you you got to send that
stuff to military school [__] [__]
whip him into shape give me some hard
water
boy Scared
Straight this stuff you get out of the
shower it feels like there's still soap
on you even if you didn't use soap I'm
like I'm like are they what are they
pumping it in the system that's soft
water yeah and they should have told you
that cuz you need to you need to buy
bags of salt to keep putting in there
yeah there's a there's a there's like a
55 gallon drum with some sort
of solution I got I'm such an idiot I
keep going bought a [__] lemon dude I
keep going get the [__] out of you got
soft water dude I'm going to switch to
[__] I don't think you can what do
you mean no cuz the pipes it it's I
think it I think you have have to redo
the whole thing TBO get on that what do
you mean I think they put it's not like
old cast iron pipes no I think when you
decide you're going to build a home with
soft water or hard water well I don't
think they use specific pipes no it's
copper pipe okay you see it half inch
domestic what are you talking about I
just quoted it my mixing valves are
working baby I got a toilet that won't
stop running now and the super don't
return
my man this toilet you got R toet oh man
I can't figure it out what that's the
flap's probably not close no I dude iy I
dude I know about Mixon valves I know
about the flap you probably got to get
the thing redone something right this
thing [__] call youan bolt has he
ain't stopped running yet what's the
scoop I'm not getting any good answers
I'd get out of that a legitimate answer
someone has
proposed uh is use it for an ice skating
rank which is like who's that applied to
what no
dude soft water sucks it's good for the
pipes but it sucks my buddy's parents
had it in the [__] 80s and 90s man
talk about low
flow it was brutal never felt like he
had a good
shower it's not that bad it ain't great
no but I mean these are
like oh man being a homeowner Jesus you
didn't [__] look it that was the
first thing out of my mouth do the
toilets run and what's the soft
situation that's why I'm never moving to
the BB City Water hard as [__] yeah dude
hold on my water would Rob your water
dude burn your
eyes that's
crazy I mean if you're just putting salt
in it can't you just stop putting salt
in it it's not like they were pulling
the water from the [__] core of the
earth it's coming from what all the
other houses are getting I feel like
that's something though right in theory
if I just stop using the soft water why
can't you Google can you stop you can
you can I don't know yeah that's what
I'm saying I don't know how to worded to
be honest with you same what do you need
to do to I think I just got to put more
salt in the bucket no that's B that's
making it more softer I got to stop
putting salt in the bucket yes yeah
that's what I said yes how much is in
there is there a lot in
there is it full you need this just
immediately it says you need to turn the
bypass valve to set the water softener
to bypass mode to stop the supply of
soften water and turn off the water
softener there you go I would do that
immediately
yeah just put it in bypass mode how's
your pressure by the
way you cut the water then you can
usually do this with yeah I think it's
just a valve how's your pressure it's
good is it yeah yeah yeah it's good huh
I'm going to redo the redo the heads get
the heads done I got to I it's a process
it's a process you redo the heads so
when you were buying this house did I
look at it not really yeah I was going
to say you didn't see like a giant thing
of salt and be like these guys must love
pretzels it's not labeled salt it was a
55 gon where's your margarita machine it
was a 55 gon drum in the basement I
thought they had a dead body in there I
ain't going to ask no questions that I
don't need the answers to who's that the
old realtor no I'm kidding you guys are
good we'll take
it can wrap it up you can leave that
here I'm I'll take it yikes man you
think you know a guy all of a sudden
find that you got soft water get out of
here with that L dude talk about low
flow that's what I'm saying we're a
hardwater crew you're telling me I why
do you think I waited 3 months to tell
you guys I didn't have the hard to break
it to you how are those sh your voice
crack so bad you're telling
me I'm embarrassed by I do hear that's a
well that's a classy that's a rich guy
thing the soft water it's supposed to be
a rich guy thing they they redid All the
they redid All of the systems to be like
crazy top-notch high-end systems yeah
then took the
microwave don't get me start on that
stole the toaster oven um I hear this
house has me jammed up sure I do hear
you get used to it uh yeah I'm used to
it but I don't live there all the time
so when I go I want to [__] scream
but then when you take your take a
shower up up town all better yeah
blasted ain't not low flow about that
with those goddamn [__] polish supers
man they don't like low flow they open
it up love it the shower at [__] my
old place God damn it was unbelievable
you would just stand in there cuz like
getting a
massage
steaming up the whole apartment complex
loved
it K let's talk about displate oh dis
Plate's back baby gang if you're looking
to level up your home with practically
zero effort displate can displate has
you covered display creates awesome
metal posters that just take 20 seconds
to install and they won't damage your
walls so you get your security deposit
back when she throws you out yeah with
license designed from Brands like Star
Wars Marvel and League of Legends your
flimsy Blockbuster posters from high
school are getting serious upgrades gang
so do yourself a favor get over to dis
plate you're not going to be able to
close any ass when the girl comes over
with your flimsy freaking posters on the
wall get yourself at this plate and get
your weer wet that's what I'm saying
Danny dog ears over
here show you want to you want to show
your freaking classy guy you like
getting laid huh dis plate hang up your
metal Star Wars poster uh your poster
comes with everything you need to hang
it immediately just pop the included
magnet onto your wall stick your display
to it and you're all set all jokes aside
we have it out in the office we have the
Seinfeld ones they're cool uh they're
awesome one of the things most people
comment on is the Kramer poster we have
uh save up to 40% off when you click
click the link in the show notes
discount will automatically be applied
to your cart when you click the link or
use the code Garbage When you visit
display.com that's display.com code
garbage or click the link in our show
notes do it yeah
um I speaking of shower from CS uh is a
garbage to chew gum in the shower that's
[__] crazy dude that's you're too
casual if you're chewing gum in the
shower I I think the other thing I I I
think it's the opposite I think you're
too keyed up like you're like really
plotting he get some thinking done no I
don't know that's too chewing gum you
can't do don't do that that's too
[__] weird chewing gum have you guys
noticed this I feel like gum I know you
tell me
Seinfeld
has gum gotten
weaker weaker in the sense of remember
when you would chew gum the longer you
would chew it the harder it would get
and the less the flavor would be now I
feel like it gets to a point where it's
almost starting to break apart it does
like dissolve a little bit yeah what's
that all about you're just chewing more
powerfully yeah no I don't think that's
exercising it no I do agree some of the
guy it turns into like [__] mush yeah
like it starts breaking apart you get a
thing up in your gum it's real
weird is it Carson real weird it's real
weird I don't know why I'm taking heat
sorry I haven't had a good shower in
weeks I'm [__] stressed out sorry
kib's blowing apart your gum takes yeah
I mean you got to bounce this stuff by
me before we start if you're going to if
you're going to bring up some poking
holes in my
hypotheses I bet you to gang knows what
I'm talking about right in don't Pander
don't Pander right guys H me up chew me
up um I do I have become a two uh
standard I'm a two-piece gum twoce
unless I'm doing that German gum that my
wife has Airways if you can get yourself
if you get your [__] hands on a pack
of Airways from Germany see if you can
get it shipped over or something well
you know what now that will take the
[__] paint off a car now that I say
that I've been chewing that Eclipse I
always go for the the the newer
packaging the the little chicklets ones
that are in like the sleeves I I I
understand I like I might go back
tonight I'm tonight I'm going to go and
it's like another pack of Sig I know
it's it's crazy you only needed the one
I know the one the one that opens up
like you're like you're opening up a
graduation card like a wallet or
something you've been accepted to Chi
Institute put your cards in there yeah
orbits the size you're flashing it like
an FBI agent excuse
me I'm about to shower here I here
someone's got some real stank breath in
here uh I don't yeah orbits the size you
need I'm going back to the
Trident little guy I'll give you that I
was banging with that last night you
remember the Trident real thin remember
the thin it was like five pieces it was
almost like uh like you you could rip it
it was oh yeah man that was before
cardboard was in yeah that was that's
where it was all that there about 10 pie
seven pieces in there yeah it was in a
line give me a look on that old school
Trident packaging cuz I remember getting
in the bubble gum and just going through
it mhm uh what about those breath strips
I don't I feel like people put acid on
those I'm not messing with what the line
things G man I did one one time I've
seen people with those recently and they
break them out I'm like where the [__]
we were in Austin and the you asked the
Uber driver for gum and he's like I got
a breath strip I was like what no no no
no he had a breath spray no I think it
was a strip no it was a because it had
the little hoop on it oh it was it was
that Listerine keychain D which you're
bad businessman if you got [__]
mouthwash keychains you think I'm going
to let you Mace me the [__] out of
here um
crazy [__] what was I just going to say
I had T-Bone also see if you can find
anything on the the gum
wallet I had a
wallet made of gum what and you would
open it up and like 15 you remember like
the old picture things that would fall
down you'd have like the like 10
pictures in there no oh yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah they were dollar bills size
sheets of bubblegum and man I crushed
that thing in a weekend my dad was like
yo enough of that let me see if I can bu
the
Bazooka wait was the actual wallet made
of gum too I don't think that might have
been plastic that's pretty sweet dude
toy didn't pay the [__] internet bill
internet bill really something I don't
know I don't know who's paying for I I
honestly don't know who pays us God damn
it now I don't know if you're going to
be able to find it yeah I got nothing on
that I I might have had the only one I
think I bought it at like an
individually owned movie theater the
only
one one of the kind sold your fat ass
right away yeah that was big it's a
prototype obviously that I mean that was
a thing I remember they somebody sold a
yard of gum too the movie Zone in
Village shes I think it was called sold
a yard of gum it was just a [__] 3ot
piece of gum was that a stick yeah like
a long like no kidding yeah it was a
yard of gum me and packed it and we
chewed it in like 6 hours yeah I'd like
something like
that would you I D I would I bubble gum
is really it it's really it's a great
thing but it doesn't really get a lot of
love anymore and i' I think I've said
this before it's a real pain in the an
to try to find sugar gum like to go out
to go to a bodega and try to find like a
thing of uh like uh Bubblicious or
something like that they don't have that
anymore they'll do the little bangers
yeah here it is the yard stick of
original sour bubble gum 96 count sour
I like that yeah there a lot of [__]
gum a lot of gum that's good I'm going
back to the Trident old school Trident I
want to see if it if it still holds up
or if it breaks apart the way the other
[__] does but also the carrying those
packs ain't great they'll they
disintegrate quick going in and out the
keys the money there's going to be
tobacco all over those pieces of gum
that's the only problem that was always
one of those pieces of tried at the
bottom of Patty's purse with the little
the little Speckles of tobacco on it you
know it was classy that my dad used to
do um not he had always Tic Tacs in the
car light green winter green the light
but I I remember being amazed at the
consistency of like when he I never saw
them buy them it seemed but they were
just always there had always two packs
and it wasn't like he had 500 in the
glove box like just I'm like damn just
stay on top of that yeah love of tic tac
love of shs shts were great fruity shts
for get about it what a SS you don't
know what a CS is my stepdad was the
winter green CS man they they were
screaming Mees those things man they
will put some hair on your little testy
dude your eyes would be watering it's
like getting punched in the nose me my
brother would split one on
Christmas yeah you don't know search
Google it c t RS you ever got to have a
siple water while you got a search in
your mouth you [__] teeth shatter man
I remember that first time I figured
that out search are all right and I'll
take you even deeper they used to have
these thing called vamt which were
awesome they had a little dip in them
they were square a little dip in them
for the older homies and bozos that
sounds like something that gave
everybody colon cancer you don't know
you've never heard of Cs that's crazy no
you're 35 years old 33 they were the two
are you 33 yeah I am Grandpa
Jesus Jesus Christ was dead and
resurrected by your age you better get
cracking got to get a move you can't
even get to work on
[Laughter]
time that's from uh Confessions of a
dangerous mine uh I got no I've never
seen these shts before they were great
you've never seen shts that's nuts some
offbrand [__] from the not the first Hey
listen don't love me in with his old
days
get get Luke get Luke Luke there's no
way you never heard a search that's
crazy they were like National brand
commercials maybe it didn't get down to
the Backwoods of North Carolina down in
the bayou with your BC powder have you
ever heard of these
shts never what get these [__] kids
out of here you never heard of sh couple
of young guys like us the one kid's
homeschooled the other one's Rich come
on what are we doing here true probably
had homemade
ones whoa whoa whoa I wasn't
homeschooled I didn't go to Middle
School you never heard of
Cs not once what are we talk I mean that
looks like it's from the 50s well all
right listen stop lumping me in with old
days crazy yeah Luke's got good takes no
they were from the 90s how about a suet
you ever hear of a su cretz that sounds
French now they were they were cough
lingers they came in like a tin like the
way oh yeah yeah yeah it's like yeah I
do know those so how do you know suet
and you don't know CS trying to make me
look stupid those are expensive no see
rich kid what I say there you go yeah if
it's under five bucks I ain't touching
them man you never heard of Cs they were
all right suet sounds
sounds like a fancy name for like pigeon
beaks or something they serve at a fan
sounds
Japanese I'll do the suets for two
please what about what about what about
a breast
saer they look like LIF Savers but a
little green dot in the middle the blue
dot either way both depends on how you
banged that's weird you know those but
not sir yeah my brother was BIG my
brother loved those and banaka banaka oh
man [__] weird crew you are the whole
lot of you is strange bunch of horse th
Baka what the
[__] man anyway love ass Sears sure um
all right let's see here do a few more
this is from Nick uh Nick farino damn
that's a nice name that's a [__] Nick
boy that's an Italian kid right there
finina Nick farino that's good he's the
inter Intercontinental Champion Nick
farino sounds like a russler it
does farino auto body ooh yeah that's a
waste man or Fino's pizza oh that's good
yeah ferino and ferino my
lawyer they'll whack you then beat the
case uh that's pretty good all right not
as good as CS but it's pretty
good
um Nick finina sorry uh do you call the
toilet the throne or the office oh yeah
dude I hate that hit the can the John
the commode Lou commode never L pisser
is tough like the pisser dude
there's the can is the bad I got to use
the can Tommy Tommy tommmy see on the
road all whenever we're in the airport
before we get on the plane he always
goes got to go to the office I got to go
to the I hate it it's so [__] whack
to me I hate it trash bag I heard a I
heard a broad say in a show one time she
was she was a little boozed up and she's
like all right I'm going to it's uh
you're next I'm going to light him in
three but I'm going to go I'm going to
go to hit the pisser real quick and I
was like yo TOS [__] tighten it up
will you you Janice Jin go I was like a
girl can't say she's going to hit the
piss her unless she's standing up while
she's doing it or she's from Boston the
pissa the pissa sure yeah but any I'm
going to the bathroom I got to I don't
know it just it's it's
uh I thought it was strange when a girl
said [__] I got to go take a [__] yeah
that's I mean any I mean I don't I also
don't say it to my wife I got to take a
[__] hey TOS I'll be back in a minute I
got to take a [__] I will say if we're
out somewhere and I I go we're going to
have an issue that's what I say we're
gonna let's get the check we're gonna
have an issue I ain't talking political
I gotta get I got to get back to the
house this is a home
game poop I like Po I got to poop you
got a poop you got a poop poop and
tinkle I think is two good ones I always
say tinkle I got a tin tinkle yeah I
don't know no man grown man saying
tinkle it's my favorite children's show
what poop and tinkle two
detectives cut that that ain't bad hold
on a second I can do both of those
voices you want to let's write the
cartoon poop and tinkle poop and tinkle
Luke they're back to back they have
bottles all right let's see here this
one's from Alex first time long time is
a garbage to have a rat in the house
catch it and keep it as a pet man
listen mice in the house I'll allow it
if you live in the city even like the
you know country rural cuz they they
they get in those field mice there's two
different breeds of mice I'll give you
that cockroaches even in the city it
happens as long as you're not infested
if you see one once a month whatever
that is what it is but I mean rats in
the house is tough you got to be living
a rough life with rats in the house okay
um you got to get a terrier you got to
get something get a cat a rat is tough I
like Toby you go Terrier just don't [__]
around just get [__] two
Terriers but then you got to deal with
them those little [__] are mean oh
dude Chay Arena friend of the show
posted a reaction to a video that went
viral recently of these people finding
like a guinea pig in a field and they go
to like release it and the little
daughter's like oh he's going to be
great their Terrier comes through and
just mauls this thing
the golf course I worked on they had two
of them and these things would [__] they
were man they were like the hangman they
[__] rolled was like Red Redemption
uhuh or dead what's it called Red Dead
Redemption yeah dude it was bad news
yeah hold
on I want to take this in the beginning
okay my understanding is it is that if
you have mice if you see a mice or you
see a rat see a mice if you see a mouse
or you see a rat at in your home that
means there
are at least five more of each maybe
more okay so can you get the rule on
that there's a rule I think that's
cockroaches it's like for every one you
see there's there's never just one Mouse
there's never just one rat rats I I got
no experience with rats but mice there
is a in New York City there's a
difference with mice I I think there's
mice in there's mice and rats in every
building it's whether they can get into
your apartment or not of course they're
in there no I I agree with you well like
we've had it where like ones come like
there's a you can tell in New York when
you see a mouse or if you have a mouse
problem they're in there I know I'm
saying listen I'm with you you've just
disagree there's not just one guy coming
through the hole they hang out in the
inside the the but if they come and they
look for food and stuff food and water
if that if that's not there for them
they stop coming I don't know about that
it's 100% true I I don't know about you
ever been to a party where there wasn't
enough beer you aren't going back to
that party dude it's a weak ass party
that's true but there's always something
they eat the plastic bags they eat the
furniture there's always something for
them to do but listen this is listen you
have your hypothesis and you're not even
moving at all on this or they could just
go to my neighbor's house who are dirt
bags and eat there they're not going to
eat a couch when there's [__] a bag
of Doritos two two doors down you see
what I'm saying there's always that
better option in New York of they can go
get food and water they got [__] 50
Department that well this is what I'm
saying what I'm saying is if you say you
find a mouse in your house and you keep
it as a pet which I think they're
adorable they're cute they're little
it's got to be a city mice and rats are
dirty no not the city mice they're just
they're trying to make it in the city
you never saw [__] this is I I hate
this take and you're just making it for
the show no I like a cute little mouse
City M disgusting and you know that
they're living in the sewer in trash
mice aren't living in the sewer rats are
living in the sewer sewer you're telling
me there's no there's no mice in the
sewers what I was going to say is if you
keep they're not Lab Rats you can't keep
white things I ain't a fan of you can't
keep one of them as a pet because the
other ones are out there and that's like
you got their boy they're probably
coming up and putting their hand on the
glass at night when he's in the tank or
the cage sending Kites and I got some
rat stats that'll make your blood run
cold rat stats are bad there's I think I
used to have a bit in New York they're
like 8 to one or 12 to one so me you say
send the kites yeah flying kites what
does that mean that's how you send
messages in jail yeah it's like a tiny
little slips of paper okay yeah I don't
like that then there then they're around
waiting for you to make a move you fall
asleep to get the keys off your off your
thing I'm sitting there sleeping with my
feet up read the newspaper busting big
big thing of keys hanging uh watching
the Giants on a tiny
TV uh yeah I think I think it's 8 to one
and if you do 8 million people I don't
like that math 64 million rats go ahead
oh God I'm moving uh all right so
obviously if you see one rat there's
more but but these are like rats are
like the Terminator dude they have the
ability to jump around three feet into
the air that's dick height that's
terrifying oh uh four feet horizontally
and then this is nuts they can fall from
a height fly a plane they can fall from
a height they don't need to fly because
they can fall from a height of 50 feet
without getting injured yeah right out
your window chilling mhm uhuh yeah rats
are no good you can't dude the idea of
keeping any type of undomesticated rat
as a pet is insane that thing that's
like those things are built like David
goggin dude that's trying to fight you
every second of every it's never going
to be your friend it's never chilling
it's not happy it's there it's just
trying to it's always trying to get out
of there I knew I knew a guy who had pet
rats and he would let them clean his
teeth dude shut the [__] up what do you
mean wait minute they could use Dental
tools wait you said they would let he
would let them clean his teeth correct
the the rat would clean his teeth
correct with their tongues with their
hands and such they the rats are like
very they're actually very clean and
they like clean each other and [__] like
that like kind of like apes and so he
would let them crawl on his shoulders
and they would go up and they'd [__]
clean his teeth sh you hung out with
this guy not for
long I don't even know I can't look at
you the same you're hanging out with
whoa whoa no no no yeah yeah yeah that's
a one time thing that's a one time oh
that's it's crazy I got I'm out of here
I'll see you later that's how it went
dude you said a friend of
yours how many times are you over his
apartment was it more than once and and
do they take dental insurance what's
happening any optometrist over there
what's the cay I got to pay to get a
[__] cleaning I I declined this line
of questioning the grounds May
incriminate me it's your boy and you
it's not my boy we're not boys anymore
but we were friends yeah and when did
you learn about this information the rat
teeth yeah did you witness that's
something he tells you on the first date
no no no no no that came out later that
came out
later man still something's not adding
up I want to like if I was like hey if I
wasn't married and I was like hey I'm
dating this girl she has rats that they
clean her
teeth would you you would stop talking
to me yeah no yeah Toby cam just goes to
Black unless they do good work I don't
know
hey man very affordable give you a
little toy look over I got braces
on he just the rats pulling his head out
of your mouth going buddy you got
cavities I wouldn't believe Jes Christ
stick your tongue out how about some
floss Bud going back in uh Rochester
grab me a little fluoride little little
headlamp on himer that was the name of
one of the
rats call him r that was a cute name for
a rat um yeah we got to wrap it up
though gang man man I was going to think
about that r cleaning the teeth for too
long yeah that's weird I want to go home
and floss with a rat tail gang we love
you to death and we'll see you next week
peace peace